Jonah is with us in Dallas Texas hi
Jonah
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up so I'm calling today to
ask should I let my car get repossessed
or should I just like find a way to
market it better like try to sell it as
quickly as possible I called into your
show September 19th of this past year
and I told you I'm in college I'm trying
to like make it work however at the
beginning of the year I was started a
new job but it turned out it was a
really sketchy and it was going
door-to-door sales and quite frankly I
didn't feel safe doing so so it's just
something really new to me but anyway I
haven't sold my car yet because the
price I'm asking which was $18,000 it
was too high I looked on KBB and the
value for private sale is between 16,000
and $100 to seventeen thousand eight
eight hundred dollars the amount owed on
my vehicle is twenty four thousand five
hundred and if I just sell it like the
low
16100 I'm roughly in the hole between
eighty three hundred dollars you have a
way to get the eighty three hundred from
your advice on SPU and I'm watching you
online you say go it's like a credit
union I was going to do that however I
don't know I haven't I haven't done it
yet so I just don't know if I'll even
get up approved not a note they go
through credit or something like that
and you don't know mm-hmm and what are
you gonna do for a new job I'm currently
working on campus at Dallas Baptist
University and the police department I
work at least 23 hours a week and per
month I'm making at least roughly after
taxes seven hundred twenty four dollars
and forty four cents my car payment plus
insurance total out five hundred and
eighty three dollars and ninety one
cents so that's like over half of my
income yeah and I just ask because quite
frankly I have no idea
I won my mentors he mentioned during a
repo and I'm 20 years old now like I
just turned 20 this past year or this
past except January and I have the next
seven years of my life to look forward
to like when I graduate college get
married and all that like I want to
think long term and set my family up for
success instead of having that weight on
my shoulders and my future spouses
shoulders like we can get approved for a
mortgage because I screwed up my credit
thanks to doing a repossession on a
vehicle yeah I'm just gonna hurt you
it's gonna hurt you for four years
probably if that oh yeah if that occurs
I'm not sure you can stop a repossession
if you don't get the car sold all right
like what what hourly war trade are you
earning with the campus police campus
police I'm making a 75 an hour
dispatcher I help
I like answer calls and all that say
okay here's the thing I don't need to do
some where you can make more money you
know yeah you're not making any money
regardless of if you keep the car or not
how are you paying for school
I have tuition sorry I have financial
aid through the United States government
also have a scholarship the CLS
scholarship Christian Leadership and so
far this semester everything is taken
care of except I need to come up with
three hundred and twenty five dollars
which is like a huge blessing in
disguise which and I'm really determined
to do so like I've started FPU this past
year I'm I'm really confident I have
hope now because like I cut out my
credit cards and thanks to listen to you
and Chris Hogan and Ken Coleman like
everyone on your team like I have a lot
of hope and I'm like have a plan like
get my stuff in order and oh that's yeah
here's the thing you're gonna be okay
either way there's no a life-ending
life-altering decision permanently it's
gonna but there's a smarter way and a
dumber way to do this what I'd like to
see that you said you've got help from
the government are you former military
no sir I don't I just did the Pell Grant
yeah okay Federal Pell Grant and like
some student loans
well okay alright alright so what I
would love to do is for you to make a
little more money than you're making now
and get the loan from the local credit
union to sell the car and here's why
number one that avoids the repossession
which is a harmful going forward into
your future as you said but number two
your $8,000 in the hole now when they
take the car and sell it on a repo line
they're gonna sell it for ten we're just
going to leave you twelve thousand
dollars in the hole or fourteen thousand
dollars in the hole okay and so you li
end up with a bigger problem down the
road than you have now
you control the price of the sale today
as long as you can keep the payment made
before they repo it and borrow the
difference you control all of that today
once you turn it over to them you're out
it's out of your control and they're
going to sell it for whatever they want
now granted you can come back and
probably settle that deficit with them
and you'll have a settled deficit
meaning if they sell it for ten and came
after you for fourteen you probably get
them to accept seven eight or nine for
that and pay cash for that sometime in
the future clear that problem off your
credit but the repossession will still
be there and would keep you from buying
a home for you know for five years
something like that in the process so if
we can avoid that by getting an $8,000
loan by getting a better job
I would rather avoid that it avoids the
repossession and the bigger hole that
the repossession will put you in and
that's what I'm trying to do so good
luck with that and I hope you can turn
it around you're thinking it through
well especially considering all the
stress you got facing you and everything
else and so yeah good good good question
and you call me back if I can help you
further at any point see it's stuff like
that that makes me want to go to the car
dealer that sold a young guy 18 years
old who has no money
a car payment of $500 a month I'm
$25,000 and see that's just morally
wrong I said well he has the right to
buy it he's an adult yeah he's the right
to buy he's an adult but at what point
doing business do you not know you're
just screwing people I mean that car
dealer ought to be tarred and feathered
for doing that loan and that substandard
subprime lender
he took an 18 19 year-old young guy has
an absolutely no money he's on Pell
Grant he's got no money you sell him a
20 something thousand dollar car on a
500 something dollar car payment um yes
that young man has a he's culpable he
has a responsibility for his actions he
is a technically an adult legally I got
all that but just because somebody's an
adult doesn't give you the right to
screw that's just wrong it's just wrong
it's out of control and he's stuck he's
in a mess
wish we could just wave a wand and make
that go away for him